quand vous aurez travailler toute votre
vie vous aurez un une retraite qui vous
permettra de vivre dignement jusqu'à la
fin nos jours et que cette retraite s'il
ya des hausses des prix s'il ya de
l'inflation et bien cette retraitée elle
augmentera et elle vous garantira vos
vieux jours c'est ça le pacte social
qu'on met avec les générations à venir
moi je vous rejoins sur une chose
monsieur 4,9 moi dans mon programme il
ya
l'ambition d'avoir d'augmenter
l'espérance de vie des français en bonne
santé de trois ans parce que je veux
refonder notre santé et je veux une
politique de santé lui disant je veux
elle stagne depuis dix ans à 64 ans et
nous avons dix ans de moins d'espérance
de vie en bonne santé que par exemple un
pays comme la suède aura la retraite non
moi ce que je propose c'est de refonder
pardon monsieur 4,9 je vous ai pas
interrompu moi je propose de refonder
une vraie politique de santé avec de la
vraie prévention y compris au travail y
compris dès l'école et de pouvoir
augmenter cette espérance de vie en
bonne santé et là dessus je vous rejoins
ça doit être un objectif prioritaire de
notre politique de santé pourquoi fo
mais parlons dans pardon
le sujet aujourd'hui c'est est ce que
les retraites pendant ces cinq dernières
années ont baissé ou pas en pouvoir
d'achat réel oui ou non bien sûr
pourquoi mais parce qu'on ne consacre
pas l'argent nécessaire à financer les
retraites madame pécresse alors
très bien mais on france allait inventer
quelque chose de formidable ça s'appelle
la sécurité sociale chacun cotise selon
ses moyens reçoit selon ses besoins est
ce qu a permis que la france est un des
taux de pauvreté des retraités les plus
faibles même si et peut-être on sera
d'accord il reste beaucoup à faire c'est
qu'à mesure que la part des seniors dans
la population a augmenté on a en
proportion toujours augmenter la part de
notre richesse consacrée aux retraites
et vous ce que vous voulez faire c'est
une rupture historique avec cela voulait
dire aux français c'est vous qui allez
vous payer vos retraites uniquement en
travaillant plus longtemps de la même
manière vous venez de parler à un stand
n'augmente à ce jeu pourquoi marine le
pen ne veut pas débattre avec vous c'est
parce qu'en fait on peut pas en placer
une donc je peux s'il vous plaît vous
expliquer même allez vous expliquer
quand même je désherbe en raison de
salaires et pécresse à l'isie parce que
j'aimerais bien expliquer le sujet le
sujet c'est qu'il ya trois ya trois
paramètres le nombre de retraités le
nombre d'actifs et le taux de cotisation
c'est à dire ce qu'on va cotiser
aujourd'hui avec votre système votre
système de retraite à 60 ans c'est 33
milliards d'euros à trouver en plus
d'aujourd'hui moi mon système c'est 20
milliards d'euros qui permettront de
deux qui seront données aux retraités
supplémentaires par rapport à
aujourd'hui donc on à 53 milliards de
différence entre nous et partagent non
non non non c'est pas hésité une
question de partage c'est très simple
les français vont comprendre aujourd'hui
à mon personnes qui gagnent 1400 euros
net mois je veux lui baissé ses
cotisations retraite de drones 105 et
non je veux lui paie ses cotisations
selon lui augmenter son salaire de 3% en
mai donc non je veux lui augmenter les
cotisations je veux s'avère non je veux
baisser les cotisations retraite c'est
l'état qu'il éprouvera à la charge et je
lui augmente son salaire net donc les
ans vous vous vous voulez non vous
voulez vous voulez
vous allez raser gratis non mais c'est
ce qu'elle dit c'est ce qu'elle dit le
début pas d'augmentation d'impôts vous
vous voulez vous voulez ou le faire 33
milliards de dépenses supplémentaires ça
veut dire que la personne qui gagne 1400
euros nets il devra payer 600 euros de
plus de cotisations retraite pour
permettre qu'on maintienne le pouvoir
d'achat des retraités alors moi je vous
explique ce que je veux faire moi je
veux que le pouvoir d'achat des
retraités soient indexés sur l'inflation
je ne veux plus comme cette année voire
des retraités qui ont une inflation à 4
% et qui se retrouvent avec un pour cent
de revalorisation je veux l'indexation
automatique comme pour le smic dès qu'il
ya 2 % de hausse des prix je veux que
les retraites complémentaires puisse
être aussi revaloriser à l'inflation là
j l'agirc arrco cette année c'est 1% et
puis grâce à ma réforme alors ma réforme
elle s'appliquera elle s'appliquera
évidemment pas aux français qui sont
usés par leur travail parce qu'il y aura
une négociation avec les partenaires
sociaux y aura un dialogue social pour
parler des carrières longues pour parler
de la pénibilité mais en revanche ce que
je souhaite et c'est très important
c'est que je souhaite que grâce aux
ressources de cette réforme toute
personne à cotiser toute sa vie partent
avec une retraite au moins égale au smic
net au moins égale au smic net c'est à
dire je fais un nouveau pacte avec la
jeune génération
aujourd'hui je vous dis si vous
travaillez jusqu'à 65 ans vous partirez
avec une retraite digne une vraie
retraite un smic net et ça vous
permettra de faire face aux vrais
besoins de votre vie et du grand âge
parce qu'aujourd'hui ça coûte combien
une place en ehpad en reste à charge
pour une famille ça coûte très cher donc
on a besoin de revaloriser aussi les
retraites et pour les revaloriser et
bien il n'y a pas 36 solutions il faut
travailler plus longtemps